want to be careful out there those winds
are going to be picking up today so if
you are headed out of the valley
Southwest winds expected 30 40 50 miles
an hour gusting through the afternoon so
if you look off to the east we have
pretty good breaks in the clouds with
some early light but off to the West boy
the mountains are still socked in with
the clouds and we've been having some
pretty good wind up in the spring
mountains Kyle Canyons had gusts to near
40 miles an hour overnight consistently
too lots of 50s with the cloud cover
overnight and some 40s out on the west
side outside the valley it's a little
bit cooler not much really 49 Mesquite
low 50s Indian Springs getting Breezy
there a few breezes for Pahrump and
getting a little windy over the mountain
spring Summit between Pahrump and Las
Vegas 52 in Boulder City 55 in Laughlin
and the winds have been gusting up
around Reno and Carson City our rain
last night was pretty steady I mean it
came in late in the afternoon and lasted
all the way until almost midnight and
then we've still been getting some
pretty good snow estimates up there at
Lee Canyon so far are up to about a foot
of snow but over in the Owens Valley and
the Sierra around the Owens Valley
around 10 000 feet about 47 inches of
snow now has been measured ten thousand
feet unbelievable and there's more snow
more rain on the way as the cold front
continues out of the West we've had over
two inches of rain in the mid elevation
levels of the spring mountains Red Rock
four tenths of an inch Northwest Valley
about two tenths of an inch and the
middle of the valley less than 507 inch
so we do need another round of rain for
many neighborhoods so the cold front has
been triggering thunderstorms with
lightning and we do expect to get a
taste of those today as more rain and
that snow moves in snow levels are going
to drop too once that cold front goes
through winter storm warnings for our
local mountains still in effect until 10
o'clock tonight as we expect maybe
several hours of very heavy snow through
the day wind advisory from noon until 7
PM for Clark County again look for those
winds sustained between 10 and 30 miles
an hour and gusts 40 to 50. we'll see if
we can make to about 60 degrees today
and again if you hear thunder that means
lightning is not far away and we do
expect that we could see some
thunderstorms today tomorrow mostly
sunny skies will dry out for a few days
rain back Sunday and Monday night